l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion en nouvelle lecture du projet
de loi de finances pour 2024 nous en
venons à la seconde partie et la parole
est à madame la Première
ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés alors
que vous venez à l'instant pour la
trisème fois sur ce projet de loi de
financeces de rejeter une motion de
censure les délais constitutionnels se
rappellent à nous et tandis qu'ils se
rapprochent une chose est clairire nous
ne pouvons pas nous passer d'un budget
nous ne pouvons pas nous passer d'un
budget d'investissement qui renforce
l'autorité de l'État et accorde des
moyens sans précédent à notre justice
notre pour notre sécurité et pour nos
armées nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
d'un budget vert qui porte les
investissements en faveur de la
transition écologique à 40 milliards
d'euros nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
d'un budget qui renforce nos services
publics et notamment notre école nous ne
pouvons pas nous passer d'un budget de
responsabilité conforme à notre
trajectoire de diminution des déficits
publics nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
d'un budget amendé et enrichi grâce au
travail parlementaire grâce à la
majorité et aux oppositions grâce à la
Assemblée nationale et au Sénat aussi
sur le fondement de l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la deuxème partie et l'ensemble du
projet de loi de finances pour 2024 je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre l'Assemblée nationale
prend acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément au disposition de l'article
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution le texte
sur lequel la première ministre engage
la responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au contre-endu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 aléa 1er du règlement le
débat sur ce texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure
déposée avant demain 20h25 est votée
dans les conditions prévues à l'article
49 de la Constitution dans l'hypothèse
où une motion de censure serait déposée
la Conférence des Présidents fixera la
date et les modalités de sa discussion
la séance
élevé